hello, how are you, greets him and
jaramillo with their brief informative today,
tuesday september 21, a mother from
northwest vigués died after being
shot by her own son, according
to detectives, the shooting was
registered on monday at the
family home near the streets  camino el
dorado and kristen the police reported that
the 31-year-old son shot his
64-year-old mother and today he is detained
in jail the father of the suspect
told the authorities that his son was
bipolar suffered from schizophrenia and
took medication for  treat these
diseases
the investigation into the cause of the
fire that destroyed the historic
outermost continues but the
clark county fire department believes that the
fire was not
intentionally set and that it was most
likely ignited in the warehouse located
below one of  canteens
where machinery and power tools are found
researchers say there are
a variety of causes  likely but
for now the official cause remains
undetermined
and clark county leaders who are
considering identifying
medical misinformation as a
public health crisis
county commission members will vote Tuesday on whether to
pass a resolution aimed at
combating misinformation about the
vaccines and the use of masks
today the win yen stadium will be
organizing an in-person job fair
these types of events take place physically
every Tuesday from 2 to 6 in the afternoon the
positions include for security
customer service cashiers waiters among others
for more information you can visit
our online page or the section in
Spanish
and now we move on to your
weather forecast a sunny day is expected with a
maximum of 92 degrees for the first day
of autumn temperatures will rise to
97 degrees have a good day I am salt
and jaramillo  and this was his brief
inclusion briefing in Spanish